The answer is that this third
step here is problematic.
And it's problematic because there
are languages where the maximum string
length is unbounded.
Remember that languages can have
an infinite number of strings.
So there are languages where,
no matter what length you pick, there is
a string in the language that is longer.
This union excludes any such language,
because each Si is restricted to
having strings of length at most i.
In fact,
none of the languages in this union
even contain an infinite
number of strings.
One particular language that is
not in this union is sigma star,
the language containing every string.